Well, hello again, everyone.
And, hopefully you managed to
find your way in.
Hope we didn't
keep you waiting
too long.
It's a pleasure today to be
introducing in,
knowledge connection
twenty twenty,
someone I know for,
well, over a decade,
I guess. We have,
the pleasure of
having, Mihir,
with us today from, Spinken.
And Michiel and I,
actually were
colleagues for a brief
while, back in Amsterdam,
like I said,
over over ten years ago.
We were both in related areas
in knowledge graph,
what today actually is called
knowledge graph.
Back then, it wasn't
called that,
but you know, same
same difference.
The topic was still the same.
His was more on
the visualization
and UI UX side,
and I guess he's
he's kept to that.
And this is what he's here to
talk about today as well.
So I'll get out of the way and
let me hear it.
The only thing to
mention to you,
if you want to
share anything,
like questions,
comments or anything else,
by now I guess you
know the process,
this little chat box.
I'll keep an eye on it and in
the end of the presentation
address your questions and
comments to be here.
So the floor is
yours. Thank you.
Welcome, everybody.
Nice to be here
and nice to see
some familiar people
in the participants
, list. Alright.
Can you put on my
my screen share?
I should pause that and then
quickly switch to this one.
You should be able to
see my slides now.
Right? So let's put
it in full screen.
So for Fog Worldwide,
I'm going to talk
about so this
is a project you
have been working
on the last months.
I work for a company
called Spink.
You see the logo
here at the bottom
left. We are actually
in the business
of creating search
solutions for
for knowledge graphs.
And we're gonna have a look at
how we apply that
here for this
project for worldwide.
So before I say
anything else,
I should really give credit to
the organizations
and the people
that were involved
in this project.
So here at the top,
you see three
cultural heritage
organizations in
the Netherlands.
The one on the right,
you're probably
familiar with.
And here at the bottom,
you see some other companies,
more technology companies,
design companies involved in
this project. And I myself,
as I said here, at SPYNC.
So there's three things that I
would like to do
with you today
in this talk. Of course,
we're gonna have a look at for
a whole wide and,
why are we doing
this and how.
Next, I want to make a,
a claim for cultural heritage
organizations to
connect their data.
And finally, we're gonna have
a look at how we
employ the concept
of search design to access
knowledge graphs.
So let's start with Vincent.
So physics for
growth really is
a worldwide
phenomenon by now.
So this is a visualization of
his artworks where they are
currently located.
And as you you
might wonder what
what is here in
the Pacific Ocean?
Well, this is
actually Honolulu
in in Hawaii. Right?
So it's really
spread out to all
continents all
the way to Sydney,
Australia. And what we do in
projects like this is that we
usually start
from the end user
perspective. So
what are the search
tasks that people
are having for
this type of data.
Now you see here a picture,
a little bit empty,
as you probably can expect.
During this presentation,
we'll start filling
the rest of
this picture.
But we start here
from the right side.
So what are the users here?
Well, in this case,
these are really
professional users.
So these are researchers,
in the art humanities domain.
And you have
a couple of examples
of research questions that,
that they have from
actual people.
For example,
Verhoeff painted
several artworks
from the family
Houlain in France.
So which members of the family
did he actually paint?
A much more
complicated question
is this one. So,
for several artworks
of van Gogh,
it's not exactly
known when they
were painted. And
sometimes also
the order of in which they are
painted was this one before
the other one is not known.
And finding this out
is a big topic.
And they use a lot
of information
from that. From this range is
really from analyzing
the paint,
the actual material
to the canvas,
that it was was used for.
For example, it's
two paintings
use canvas from
the same role.
This is, of course,
an indication that they were
created close by in time.
Another picture,
another question is
actually, I think,
for someone else
attending now,
is more sort of
a social aspect,
right? So how are
the paintings
of a book perceived
throughout time,
right? They are exhibited for
more than a century.
And how were they perceived?
How were they
exposed together?
How was it how
did people write
about those paintings?
And how did that
change throughout
the decennial? All right.
So that should have given you
an idea what we're
trying to do here.
So let's just go there.
So you should see
now, the website,
and, let's try to start with
the the simple
question that you
just saw. Let's search for,
Now what you see here is six
paintings made by.
The first thing that I have to
say is that these are actually
not all the paintings
by this family.
Because at the moment,
we have collected
all the paintings,
or all artworks,
I should say,
in in the Netherlands,
from a dozen institutions.
The second phase is,
is currently starting.
And in this phase,
we're going to collect
all the information
from the other institutions.
But already plenty
to see here.
But of course, this is not so
spectacular yet.
I mean, this you can also see
see on Wikipedia.
So let's dive into it
a little bit more.
So for example, this,
this cute little boy, again,
becomes more
interesting because
already here on
the right side,
you see images
and becomes even
more interesting
if I open this
because these are actually
available in high resolution.
So this means I
can can zoom in
and and look at
these boys' eyes.
And this becomes even more
interesting if I start looking
at more technical
recordings of,
of this painting.
So this is what is
called breaking
light, where
the light is shared
on the painting
from the side.
And this really gives a good
view on how Vergoc used his
paint to to get all
kinds of effects,
right, the thickness of the of
the paint here.
Another thing that's very
interesting is
this canvas is,
of course, stretched
on a frame.
And this frame contains all
kinds of information. Right?
So there are are
label stickers
on it that indicated who has
owned this painting
and, where it was,
for example, exhibited.
So here is actually one from
nineteen twenty eight
from an exhibition
in Germany.
Later in time, I guess they
wanted to protect
this frame and
they added a cover
on top of it,
which when you borrow
the the painting,
you're not allowed
to take off.
So the more recent exhibitions
actually have their,
their stickers here on the on
on this back panel.
Okay, so let's close this high
resolution few and
scroll down a bit.
Of course, there is object
metadata about the artwork.
But there's also
various other things.
For example,
van Gogh has written a lot of
letters to mainly
to his brother,
but also some to
some colleagues.
In his letters,
he he often mentions
his artwork.
So the same for
for this artwork.
So you can read about,
what he said about that.
Who has previously
owned these artworks,
going from his brother to,
to where it's
currently located.
And here we see those,
those exhibitions.
So what we saw there,
the sticker at
the background,
on the on the frame
in nineteen
twenty eight is actually this
exhibition. So we
can click this
exhibition and now see which
other artworks were
also exposed there.
And so that gives you,
a completely different
perspective,
on the artworks.
Now there are various other
things that you can,
can explore yourself,
after this presentation.
So let's get back,
to the presentation.
So what we've done now,
we've we've seen sort
of the user side.
So what's happening
in the background?
Of course, there's
all kinds of
data coming from,
from institutions,
and somehow we want to create
a knowledge graph
out of this.
Now I want to
approach this part
of the talk from a sort of
personal insight that I gained
during this project.
I've been working
in in Credoheads
already for, for about fifteen
years coming from
this technical
perspective. But
what I realized
in this project is that there
really is a wealth
of knowledge
in these this organization.
So you can truly call them
knowledge institutes.
But what surprised me is that
only a small part of this
knowledge is actually
available online.
So, of course,
these numbers are
speculative that I
that I present here.
And this will not be
the same for all.
For some, this will
be a lot more.
But in general,
there's really a lot of stuff
that is not available
online yet.
What we managed to do with is
to increase this.
And so, for example,
these exhibitions
that I showed
you in the high address,
photos are now
made available.
So in that sense,
FOCO worldwide has has helped
to reach the full
potential for
for cultural organizations.
But what I truly
believe is that,
for the cultural heritage
organizations themselves,
there is so much potential to
gain if they start to,
organize themselves around
connected data.
So not only just
for sharing it
to other portals,
but also for
themselves because
it will empower them to do so
many more things and truly be
a a knowledge
institute on the web.
So, that's almost,
almost a call out to these
organizations. So how should
they do this then?
Well, this should start with
within their organization.
And so there's not just this
collection management system
from which you
see a screenshot
here on the left
with this typical
object metadata.
That was actually
the stuff that
I have known for years.
But there is so much more.
And so you have already seen
some of those assets.
And some of the things
you haven't
seen is also x
rays or infrared
photography. There's
really a wealth
of information there.
Then there was
documents, literature,
research reports,
publications,
all discussing and providing
interesting perspectives.
So the organization
should really
organize this and
start connecting
this data.
Secondly, they should connect
to external authorities.
And there is a lot of
knowledge inside,
but outside, there
is a lot that
can complement this.
And here you see a couple of
examples for people
in the cultural
heritage domain,
probably familiar
with something
known as the art
and architecture
or in short, AT.
This provides very
rich information,
for example, about materials,
type of paintings, etcetera.
Of course, literature,
for example,
as as modeled in Fiaf.
And in the Netherlands,
is a very interesting source
collecting information
about artists,
museums, owners,
etcetera. Right?
So all this
information provides
a way of integrating data and
at the same time providing
additional backgrounds
information.
Okay, so given
these two things,
connecting inside
and connecting,
adding external information to
the inside. How to do that?
Well, very good
news that since,
since a while now,
there is a community effort in
this domain, on
a shared data model.
And they call
this linked art.
And this is a very
nice initiative
because what it does,
it really tries to
find a sweet spot,
on top of a very
expressive model,
which is called CDOS AM,
but which is maybe
a bit complicated
to use. And what
LinkedAR managed
to do is really
reach the sweet
spot that made it possible for
organizations to
start using to
start express all this which
which information
that they have.
And, now here you see
a snippet of that.
Of course, we're not go gonna
go into detail.
But I do wanna
point out a couple
of things here.
So for example,
the reference to an AT concept
here and the reference
to a place.
And And also interesting here
is the modeling of dates,
which actually allows you to
model vagueness in dates.
So that brings me to the last
one is that
the quality of data
is really a big thing.
So a lot of time during this
project was actually spent by
the data owners in improving
their quality. And
so in the collection
management systems,
they often,
for example, use not
complete dates.
And this this is
the case because
they don't they
don't know the exact
exact date. It's
either in a period
that is made or
they don't know
exactly when it
started or ended.
And by allowing
them to actually,
model this fakeness,
we can then start doing things
like sorting updates,
which is of course
not possible
if you don't have
a well formed date.
But there are various other
issues in data
quality as well.
Now what we notice
in this project is,
expressed here by
this, by this quote.
So you can read it yourself.
So what really
happened is that
once they saw information,
their information
being used on
the web and seeing, hey.
This is actually complete or
this is wrong. That really was
a big incentive to
start improving
the data.
One of the examples,
if you then have good data,
you have it connected
to external
authorities. For example,
here in for wide,
you see these these filters on
on the left side that you're
obviously familiar
with from all
kinds of search applications.
Now here, this
gives a very nice
overview of
the high level what
kind of different
types of objects
there are. If you've seen any
website that aggregates,
especially culture data from
different sources,
usually these
things are a mess,
Right? So what we do here,
we use controls
for gamblers for
all of that. Meaning also that
if you don't use them,
you will not end up
in these filters.
But we provide some sort of
flexibility because
although we
show these high level
categories here,
which was one of the wishes of
the users,
We allow also institutions to
provide many more
specific things.
But by using the relations in
this thesaurus,
we can then provide the level
that we need here
in the interface.
So we use
the background knowledge
for that. All right.
Let's come back
to this picture.
So we've seen now,
coming from the right side,
that we start to understand
the search tasks that
are involved here.
We have seen how organizations
can capture their knowledge,
and they've
actually been doing
that themselves. Right?
So this is not that we start
harvesting their
data and do this.
They actually have been doing
this themselves,
which was really cool for us.
But clearly in this picture,
there's there's a gap
in the middle.
Right? So how are we going to
solve the search task using
using this knowledge graph?
That brings me to this part.
And, we obviously,
we need some sort
of API, right,
that goes to the website.
And but what
happens before that
is what we call
relevance models.
And I'll explain to you why we
call it relevance models.
Because what it has to do with
for us is actually three type
of queries. And if
you're familiar
with with graph data,
you're familiar with
the first Right?
So structured graph queries,
for example, give me
all the artworks,
and and sort them by
by the production
date. Now that's a very
valid question.
But in applications
like this,
there's usually a full text
component as well.
So what about
the documents that
mentioned for folks health?
And in fact, in most cases,
they combine these
things, right?
So there is structured and
unstructured
information combined,
right? So in particular,
this unstructured part,
we're starting to
deal with relevance,
right, aboutness.
It's not just true or false.
And what I like to show you is
how we solve these
things in SpeedDesk.
So what we're trying to do is
to really allow
people to create
these relevance
models themselves.
So what you should
see now is,
is being desk, which should be
run as a as a cloud service.
And, here,
the the full API of
the of the application
is, shown here.
This is basically
the whole API,
of the application.
And for each endpoint,
they are implemented
as what we
call strategies or
in other words,
relevance models.
And what I want to do with you
is to actually create one.
Not exactly what
we use in these
applications, but just to
illustrate how we do that.
And we do that in a visual
programming interface.
So here on the left side,
we have a library of
building blocks.
And what we can do is we can
drag those blocks
onto the convos,
and there we can
start creating
relevance models.
So to start with,
I'm just gonna
take all the data
that we have. So basically you
can say this is
this is the graph
that we have. And what I want
to do here is I want
to make a search
engine for all
the letters that
Verkhof wrote.
So I'm not gonna
take all the data,
but actually dragged
in another block.
And I'm going to
filter my data
on messages. So as
you notice here,
these are modeled
with schema dot org.
So I select the messages.
Now I can inspect the output
here of this block.
And we see here on the right
side information.
Let me increase
this a little bit.
So here are,
the number of letters.
Now this is not a lot.
This is nine hundred three.
But let's let's
create a search
engine for this.
For example, we're
using the text
of those letters.
So what I can do
is I can actually
extract this text.
There we go.
And I configured
this to actually
take the text that
we want to use.
And now we can say,
let's build a document search
engine for this.
So this is a particular
relevance model.
And in fact, this is actually
the model that is
used by by most,
off the shelf search engine
systems like Solr,
Elasticsearch.
So, basically,
what we're doing,
we're building that
here on the spot.
So we just miss one
component here,
namely the input,
And let's say for now that we
want to search for
mental health.
Maybe we configure our search
engine a bit. I
know that we're
talking about English here,
so let's apply some stemming.
And now the magic
happens because
when I start inspecting
the outputs,
what the system
does for you is
actually create
the indexes that
are required. Right?
So and in this way,
you as a user don't need to
think about what are
the the technical
aspects that I
need to realize,
what kind of index do I need.
But you can think at a much
higher abstraction level,
what should my relevance model
actually look like.
And what you see now that we
actually find all
kinds of results,
and these are
ranked as you can
see here in this probability
distribution. And
at the beginning
we see here,
maybe we're not maybe we're
actually not gonna
expect these results,
but what if we start
analyzing them?
So we go sort of
back to our graph.
And let's say now
we're interested
in which periods these letters
were written. So I'm going to
extract actually the date that
they were sent.
There we go.
And here we are at eighteen
eighty nine and
eighteen eighty
eight is the most
relevant years.
Now it turns out that actually
cut off his ear,
in December eighty eight.
So it's not surprising that
around this time,
he was writing mostly about
about this mental health.
We can also do something
else and say,
hey, let's now
look to something
completely different.
So from those letters,
let's move to the artworks.
And the artworks that he has
mentioned in those letters.
So what are actually
the artworks
most involved in this whole
topic of mental
health health?
Now this is probably a bit
difficult to read for you.
On the website they're
nicely formatted.
But here you see that painting
of Madame Goulain,
which was actually painted at
the end of eighty eight.
And here's another painting of
of the sunflowers all sort of
in that that period.
Now I hope this
gave you an idea
how you can play
with these things,
create relevance models over
over both the text
and the structured
structured part.
If I am correct,
I have, like,
one minute left.
So let's briefly then look at
how we are doing this.
So if you're sort of in the in
the knowledge graph domain,
you're you're
familiar with this
picture. Right?
So what we have
at the bottom,
oh, sorry. At the top,
the top of the iceberg is some
sort of API that is used by,
by an application.
Underneath that,
there is some sort of graph
database and and a graph
query language.
And what's what we find very
interesting is to look at what
are now the rules
that are needed
to solve these things. Right?
We need some
developer to create
these things. And
this is typically,
yeah, just below the surface,
just above the surface.
Now if you need
full tech support,
then typically
this is added on
the site.
And although there
are solutions here,
it's not very easy to combine
these things.
And what you need
of course is someone that now
has knowledge of
both these things.
So what we're trying to do,
we actually push
the technology
all the way down.
So at the lowest level,
we actually implemented these
things in one system,
which is a probabilistic
graph database.
On top of that,
we have
a probabilistic relation
to algebra that can deal with
these things. And if you're
interested in that,
you can read about
that in the literature
. Oh, sorry about that.
But most importantly for us is
that all of this is now under
the surface. But
above the surface,
we now have a way that we can
support
information specialists
to deal with
accessing knowledge
graphs and text
in the same same
way to create relevance models
that are needed for,
for an application.
And that is what I just just
showed to you.
So to wrap this up,
a lot of knowledge
potential in
corporates organizations.
But for that, they really need
to understand the users.
They need to capture their
knowledge and finally model
the relevance that
is needed for
the applications.
Great. Thanks.
Thanks, Miguel.
Well, great, great slides.
We have some some
questions from,
people, but, you know,
I'll seamlessly take advantage
of my position here,
and I'll I'll make
the the first
question because, well,
you you triggered my interest
with something you said.
So you mentioned you're using
a probabilistic
graph database.
I'm supposed to be the expert
on graph databases,
but I've never
heard about it.
Would you like to say, like,
a couple of words
of What it is?
Who built it? How
it works? Yeah.
So so the work
originated actually
in database or actually to be
more precise is the merger of
two fields,
relational databases
and information retrieval.
At the end of the 1990s,
work was done there.
And And basically
what it means
is adding a score column to,
to a triple or quadruple.
So we have lifted it
from the database
world to, to
the graph, world.
So, where we add scores.
And now what do you do with
these scores? The interesting
thing is that
the research that
I showed you there,
there are various
there is an algebra
to deal with these
scores. Right?
How how to combine them,
how to add them,
how to multiply them for for
different operations.
So at the lowest level,
there is actually
graph scores,
but more importantly
is at the top
level is then how you how you
use those scores for
certain operations.
Okay. Okay. Well, yeah,
you you provided
the reference,
and I guess,
I or anyone else
who's interested
will will have to look it up.
But, yeah, it's it's a very
interesting concept.
And, let's see
what people have
been asking. K.
Another question is,
which is very
specific I guess,
what is the rank
by text block?
And I get it's tied to one
specific slide you
had. Yeah, yeah.
So I use the rank by text or
more specifically,
I use the rank by
BN twenty five,
which is a relevance model.
And so so this is used by
Elasticsearch as well.
And, what it does,
it implements this
for for you.
Right? So the the actual query
that you need, is implemented
in that path. So basically,
you can grab whatever entities
you have in your
Knowledge Graph
and say, I need this text and
sort of throw it
in Elasticsearch
as you want. But
the nice thing
is you don't need to because
the system does it for you.
So we actually
create the indexes
that you need to create that
search engine. So it all runs
into the same system. Okay.
Well, like many
people are saying
in in the comments,
that sounds really,
really cool, actually.
Another question and
again from from me,
you mentioned that certain
vocabulary at some
point linked the art,
if I recall,
And you said it's
kind of good,
sweet spot, middle
ground, between,
different expressivity,
methods.
And you also mentioned that it
allows you it's
kind of it allows
to deal with vagueness and
specifically
vagueness in dates.
So would you like
to expand a little
bit on the expressivity
part and
then maybe
specifically on the on
the vagueness? Yeah. Yeah.
So what I specifically said is
that it finds the right sweet
spot between expressivity and
ease of use. And so you could
almost position it between,
schema dot org,
which is relatively
easy to use.
But for something rich and
heterogeneous as we needed it
for cohort wide,
it was it was
just not enough.
And at the other hand,
there is something
known as CDOC CRM,
which is an event
based model,
which allows you
to model a lot
of stuff. But,
to figure out how to use it is
a bit complicated.
So what Linked Art has done is
what they call
an application profile.
So under the hood,
they actually use
Cedarc Serum,
the user classes,
the user relations,
the actual stuff.
But they created
what they call
an application
profile in JSON LD.
So you can actually write it
down quite simple
in simple terms.
And this is
a community effort.
So it's full of
documentations,
the patterns that
you need come
from actual use
cases from actual
institutions. And,
we had we had some
discussion with them.
There were a couple of things
that that we needed and things
were changed. So this
is still ongoing,
but this really
suited our needs.
So if that would not have been
that this this would be quite
a quite a drama to to do.
So, so that that's
that sweet spot.
And the other question, yeah,
about the dates.
And so in this
domain, people say,
late late autumn,
eighteen eighty
eight or October
nineteen hundred.
And what it allows
you to do is
basically define
the vagueness,
of a period. So
there are things
like the begin of the begin,
the end of the begin,
the beginning of the end,
and the end of the end.
And so you describe vagueness
of periods where the where but
you use actual excess dates.
So for a system,
you now have proper dates that
you can use. They might not be
the exact date, but
at least you can,
for example, sort
on something.
And typically this
is accompanied
then by textual description,
something like late
autumn eighty eight,
which you can display
in the interface.
So it sort of
gives you the best
of both worlds. Okay. Yeah.
I don't know. I mean,
both of those things
that you described,
well, the, the way that,
people have worked
with elite,
art vocabulary to me
sounds, you know,
exemplary, basically.
So making it easy for,
developers to use,
by by leveraging JSONRT and
doing these different profiles
that you mentioned.
And then on
the dates, this is,
like, a, you know,
notoriously difficult issue,
how to manage
overlapping dates
and even more back dates.
So if they manage to
to address that,
that's that's
super cool. Yeah.
Yeah. Of course,
they need to
create this data.
Right? And,
what you saw in
this project is
that
the the larger institutions
like the Hoch Museum,
the Rijksmuseum,
they were doing these
things themselves.
So they have their
own pipelines
for creative data mappings.
For smaller institutions,
we actually help
them with it.
I mean, smaller in
sense of for whole,
right? So people
providing like
ten artworks. So what I didn't
show you that in Spring Desk,
there is a part where you can
actually create those
mappings as well.
So we help them
with that part.
Okay. Let's see.
I think we may have
one last question.
I'm getting to actually show.
Says, technically,
using the SPYNC tool requires
to upload data
into a proprietary
database.
Yes. I mean,
we're coming a bit
from the search area.
So often we actually
call it an index.
Yeah. Right. So it's
sort of a layer
on top of your data.
So we're not the data
management system.
We interface or
we connect with
existing systems.
So, yeah, but that
is required.
So we're not doing
federated search.
That that that
that is clearly,
something different.
Okay. Yeah.
That's that's that's
clear. Alright.
Well, thanks,
thanks once again,
to you, Michiel,
and to everyone who attended.
We'll have to wrap up here so
we can move to
the next session.
So, see you there,
and see you also in
the next session.
Bye for now.